ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences John Bailey
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening everyone it's an honor to
be here with all of you this evening
this is my first student Academy Awards
as your president I'm doubly honored to
salute so much young talent at the cusp
of their careers all of you student
filmmakers will we hope and expect be
able to engage and enthrall us for
decades to come and that's what the
student Academy Awards is about not just
the celebration that introduces the
world to names like Robert Zemeckis and
John Lasseter cary fukunaga Trey Parker
and Spike Lee but a movement which
through the example of more recent
winners like Patricia Riggins and
Patricia Cardozo is helping to break
Hollywood's class ceiling by supporting
more talented women directors in our
industry
[Applause]
it's also a wonderful opportunity for my
generation to introduce all of you
emerging filmmakers here tonight to the
Academy we at the Academy need you we
need you to dream and to discover to
learn and to teach in an art form built
on big dreams we need you to lead the
next generation who will take movie
magic to new heights of daring and
artistic excellence and that is why
that's most important with the awards we
are giving to you tonight but what you
will give to all of us during your
lifetimes as creative filmmakers as a
filmmaker who has committed to film
history and preservation I'm reminded
every day how much we stand on the
shoulders of the supremely gifted men
and women who have for over 100 years
spent their lives in cinema but I'm
reminded even more that we filmmakers
like film itself not to mention digital
or temporal we all come into the world
with expiration dates so we are counting
on you the next generation to keep our
art form vital with your talent and new
visions this year as we have since 1972
we honor an exciting group of filmmakers
in future academy members and we can
only do it thanks to the unprecedented
record-breaking 468 Academy members who
have served as judges who have chosen
carefully from the 1587 entries from 356
schools to each of you thank you
[Applause]
and to all of the entrants and winners
in this year's competition a well
deserved salute break a leg and now it's
my pleasure to introduce the past
student Academy Award winner and now
chairman of the Student Academy Awards a
writer and director who has traveled the
globe from India to China to tell
stories that the world needs to see a
proud member of the Academy please
welcome Greg healthy
[Applause]